hello everyone so this is one of the
first kind of podcast things that I've
done on my channel this is a
conversation with Rajat just pretty much
cover in everything site history a few
questions that I had the 4k contests are
comments on some of the recent drama I'd
general
bobdor between us so with that
explanation out of the way let's get
straight into it hello ruj Atari hello
ok so how would you like to start would
you like to start talking about the
contest or site history hey let's get
into the contest cuz that's that's
what's going on right now that's the big
hubbub on the site Jim so what
everyone's writing what everyone's
talking about ok so I'm probably the
best person to talk to you about this
cuz I I knew the contest is happening
but that's about it
hi I realize I haven't really read any
any articles so how many articles do we
have at the minute actually in the
contest I don't know it's good there's
more being posted every day I think the
last time I checked we had somewhere
between a dozen and 29 posted on the
first day and they were already 5 or 6
just on that first day well mom that's I
think that the number by the end is
probably gonna be somewhere maybe 30 or
40 entries well yeah because the the
deadlines the was it the 1st of August
yeah 1st of August and so who judges
this is it like a group of people or is
it one person there's no actual one
group judging it it's just whichever
article has the highest rating by the
end of the contest is the winner oh it's
so once I rinse ok yeah and then
everyone who enters also gets first dibs
on a whatever number slot they want in
the new series
yeah that make sense so would like um is
it everyone that enters the contest gets
first dibs on a series 5 article yeah
yeah I think that the the top three like
the number one obviously gets to be SCP
4000 and then the other to get first
first like they get double first dibs on
whatever numbers they want and then from
then everyone else is kind of
free-for-all actually speaking of which
I can't remember who he was it was that
actually told me
but is it true that at the top of every
series with the exception of series one
each each the start of every series has
a theme like a specific theme so so
because this one's history what would
the what were the previous things the
3,000 content and the 2,000 contest was
I believe science fiction yeah I think
it was sci-fi I mean I can double-check
that right now yeah science fiction okay
yeah and the 1000 contest was urban
legends oh yeah the big yeah cuz the
Bigfoot ones do anyone that I've
actually created a video on so far
because at that stage I wasn't really
properly back so I just created a normal
version book I'm thinking of actually
creating more special treatment for
those articles because enhanced version
well yeah yeah like a different take on
it but because you need to enter a
contest to actually have that slot I
think it deserves a little bit more
special treatment than their other ones
if you know what I mean yeah definitely
it's actually interesting the way that
the winners of the contests the winning
rating has expanded over time because
scp-1000 was very very close to being I
believe the article that was like a
Hanged Man with his dog hurting his body
I think that the rating for that one was
only decided on the very very last day
oh whoa and the other ones have him in
his clothes like scp-2000 wasn't that
close SCP 3000 actually that one was
pretty close I think that read reality
was closing in on a anis Aniston Asia or
whatever I don't have pronounce it as
that's exactly what I was about to say I
was like I'm glad everything has a
number on this site because if not I
honestly don't know how I would say that
yeah I always say Anastasia but I know
that that's just a Russian princess and
not the name yeah of the actual article
yeah that's that's why i'm sanna inside
my head and he's just a Stasia
just just the big the big forget he'll
nom tesha non Teixeira I don't know do
you know do you know what like the
origins of the word is because I haven't
actually I haven't even read three
thousand yep no clue I know that's it's
supposed to be like the source of all
the foundations amnesia drugs no
something like that I don't think I've
read it since the contest the one that
stuck with me the most from the contest
was actually read reality 3001 that one
actually gave me that's the last STP if
read that actually gave me like a
nightmare oh really yeah scared me just
the idea of slowly decaying while still
retaining your consciousness and just
focusing on this red light actually you
know was I think it series four is one
of the ones that I haven't really
touched on that much I think everyone
everyone he read like I'm harmful
harmful because like think of red 3063
off the top of my head I know that all
right that's the only one I can remember
off the top of my head yeah the serious
four is actually the series that I've
contributed the least to just because I
was going through a time in my life
where I was kind of busy and not super
super engaged with the site yeah but I
do have some
that I like on this series there's
there's definitely as much good content
in this one as any other series yeah I
mean like that see that that's the thing
is that you mean if you look at every
series it's subjective there's there's
certain things you're gonna like and
dislike but that's not to say they're
you know the things that you dislike or
objectively bad are the things that you
like are objectively good that kind of
thing and it's always been that whatever
the newest series is is the one that
people say is the worst one like I
remember I joined the site I joined the
site right when serious two had opened
and everyone always said yeah serious
twos are right but you know series one
is is the best and now a lot of people
on the side say that no actually series
2 is the best series yeah because I
think that's I think that's roughly when
I joined as well just whenever like the
term series became a thing because I was
a reader whenever it was just series one
but whenever I started engaging with
people and creating stuff on YouTube is
whenever series 2 became a thing so I
guess what would that be 2011 2012 yeah
that's that's uh
that's right when it's right around when
I joined it's it's we went from just
having the series to series 1 series 2
and then series 2 filled up in a couple
years
series 3 filled up and about a year and
a half two years so now series 3 has
filled up in just about a year just
buckwild to me yeah it's they're coming
in second fast yeah really it's amazing
to see how much more quickly and also
with better content because I mean
serious one took a long time and serious
one was also in my opinion it's gotten
better over time because people have
filled in deleted stuff and rewritten
stuff mmm but it definitely has I think
the most articles that are getting by on
reputation alone you know like oh before
9 was just rewritten and you know I I
haven't actually read the rewrite I
think I think I might have read it when
it was post I don't remember I remember
its
it's cats it's pretty much the same
thing but more fleshed out but the
original plague doctors is just not not
good at all yeah that's such a divisive
opinion like it's so polarizing like I
mean I never really had a super massive
problem with the original one but in my
opinion the newer one is better but from
what I can tell most of the people that
don't like the rewrite of the opinion
that it's lost its mystery annoying
which I can't really I can't really
understand because to me the story of
the character is a little bit more
compelling night but I suppose it's just
because it's a legacy character at this
point people have made their minds up
about what the character is a byte and
what he does and what he would say so
whenever they original author chose to
rewrite it they were it's like a George
Lucas scenario with star yes yes no
matter what no matter what the special
no matter how much better the special
edition is you're always gonna know but
but the others you know though pretty
much yeah
although I did think it was pretty cool
that the original author was the one who
came back and said you know we need to
we should we should edit this because
I'm not satisfied with how it how it how
it came out yeah definitely definitely
because it's like he was pretty gracious
about that because I think the original
like proposal did you ever straight DJ
cactus's proposal on the original
rewrite no I don't think so
he posted it on his blog or well it was
somebody a year ago I think um but he
he'd done his own rewrite completely
independent the real kid and I actually
posted on my channel because I liked it
so much that wasn't received well either
but um thank Gabriel G had seen nut and
as soon as he seen cactuses rewrite he
he approached him a couple of months
later I apologize if I'm getting any of
this wrong those of you listening this
is just what I could say to the best of
my knowledge I mean I wasn't I wasn't
this this all happened during the time
where I wasn't
super involved on the side I've actually
just relatively recently gotten back
into being involved in day-to-day
operations and not kind of doing duties
more behind the scenes you know I'm glad
to be back so I really enjoy the side
and it's nice to be with my friends
again no thanks I think that the main
thing about the o49 rewrite is that they
definitely did not think through the
blowback that was going to get before
they rewrote it and I think it took a
lot of took I wasn't surprised by it but
I think it took cactus and maybe I don't
know about Gabriel Jade by surprise yeah
Gabriel jeans not he's a very laid-back
mom I've never seen him get frustrated
with anything but the only misconception
that those kind of annoy me a little bit
is people think it was just the J cactus
who reroute it and uploaded it they
didn't realize that Gabriel Jie had
checked everything and hearted certain
things that cactus didn't you know it's
still the original author bringing
through his his vision just in a way
that's a little more a little more
polished and a little more it's way more
flesh than way more but but but but I
think that that's also why a lot of
people don't respond that well to
because they they already have their
preconceived opinions over before it was
flashed out this unchanging steady thing
and then suddenly with apropos of
nothing it's totally totally different
yeah pretty much
yeah well though it's always been
interesting to me to see people's
reactions to different articles being
rewritten and changed
did you know that iris was at one point
almost deleted iris which ones no that's
the photography girl 105 you can reach
into the pictures and change stuff oh
yeah yeah yeah she was she was almost
and I think that almost almost rewritten
in a way that was totally - again
totally totally different but then uh I
think it was cleft came in and clef pulp
punched it up and fixed it up okay
because I believe that the original
author author was check yeah it was
Danton deadly deadly moose it says or no
Wade no written by Duncanson sorry yeah
yeah Danson
Denton's an old old old school old
school user from way back in the day who
wrote kind of wish fulfillment he
articles but iris iris has been helped
along the way I don't think that the
original version would have aged
particularly I think that Dan Tintin
might have altered no Fritz Willy the
administrator in wrote cast I fit not
night yeah Cassie the drawing girl yes
I'm kind of remembering five things at
once oh no it's all good because I think
that you know the drawing one was one of
the first ever scps that I actually read
because I think my first one was it was
obviously one seven three but apart from
that it was sex exit which to this day
is still still my number one favorite
just because oh yeah the chef's knife oh
man it's so good like that one's crazy
ginger what's even weirder about that
though last wait oh sorry last month but
you know the way sex exits supposedly is
based on the bystander effect I learned
last month that the bystander effect was
something that was a that was a lie yeah
I did not know that I've been walking
around like tellin everybody or you
should read sexxxy it it's actually
based on a real psychological phenomenon
and then I found out last month that the
actual the science behind it was a lie
yeah I think it stemmed from the kitty
Genovese case because people around and
watched but people did call the cops on
that guy after he attacked her yeah it
was a complete it was a completely
fabricated cuz the way the way I
originally read about it was it was
about 20 people
watching this woman be assaulted and
nobody did anything whereas it was a it
was like two people seen it on one
person called the police
yeah it was just it was all fabricated
by the papers to be a sensational a
story but yeah I always loved that
because it was my first introduction to
an SCP with extensive logs for you to
read about how it was acquired and a lot
kind of stuff I really like it because
it really goes into the implications of
like the full like ramifications of an
anomaly that's always what I love to see
in an SCP when the anomaly behind it is
fully explored you feel like the author
has really really thought through like
the the implications of what exactly
this anomaly is and how it is anomalous
yeah pretty much
that's not is the kind of articles that
I really like you know ones that really
build a world around the article oh yeah
the ones that there's the one that's
suck think that that's the ones that
suck you in yet oh definitely I always
come it was like a you know you know
when it like whenever you read a book
and you don't want to put a sign that
was what made me really interested and
there CP wiki because I realized that it
was really interesting not just a
monster manual you know yeah I think
that definitely moving on from being
just on an image board and on edit this
just like pastebin the different to
being on a wiki which allowed people to
be more creative to post stories and to
kind of get more into the narrative
aspect of what these articles could do
yeah definitely I mean although at the
same time like I have a really weird
opinion on on things like because I
really like action movies right
you know just dumb action movies but I
also like really a thought-provoking
movies you know to be so what so
whenever I say monster manual I'm not
saying that as a bad thing
I'm just saying it as a different thing
if you know
yeah I think that SCP kind of has both
because we do have those standalone
interviews of just crazy creatures like
I've always really been fond of the
headlights the headlights are really
cool yeah yeah I've got a title floating
in my head I think I don't know someone
suggested to me or it might have read it
in another article but just a tail
titled kill the headlights and put it in
neutralized I don't know what it would
be about but there's just such a great
title I feel like it needs to be created
by someone at some point yeah do you
know what my first SCP that I read was
yes it was the critical tomatoes really
yeah yeah what an introduction yeah I
know I read the critical tomatoes and I
read the old man so I kind of got the
full tonal whiplash you can get from oh
my first - yeah new Kindle - my old man
oh my god
I think that was my experience I
probably would have never came back
[Laughter]
because I think if I read critical
tomorrow's I would have thought oh yeah
so this is kind of a goofy kind of
exactly good on to the Omaha Warner this
is gonna be like a goofy old man all
[Music]
right okay so next you wanted to talk
about the recent drama Sarandon well I
really wanted to just clear up some
misconceptions and give some perspective
on the site's history
yeah sure I feel like a lot of people
have been off great operating under some
false pretenses well admittedly some of
our staff bright had kind of push these
misconceptions and kind of made people
angry by saying things like
who cares what the founders thought her
founders would have thought about having
a a gay an LGBTQ pride what-have-you
logo and themes on the site but you know
in reality a lot of the founders were
either very very much pro queer Foulke
or were queer people themselves you
could look at stuff like like originally
oh seven six Abel had an addenda where
he talked about breaking up with another
another male SCP Saint that I don't
think is around anymore no and a lot of
the yeah a lot of the early admins were
were gay or very much in favor of you
know having gay themes and gay authors
things like the the gender flip stone
you know when they originally it's been
rewritten now to be better when it
originally came out it wasn't exactly a
super well written article but it was a
Pro trans article even back then in 2008
so I think that anyone who's saying that
these that adding gay identity and LGBT
identity to the site is a new phenomenon
that's big that's taking it away from
where the site came from really doesn't
know where the site came from well I
don't really agree with that kind of
thing mainly because ever since well
let's be honest that was the madacorp
video that sparked the whole thing but
ever since then even I I haven't even
addressed it publicly to be honest right
but all the some of the comments that
I've got from from people that have
mainly watched manicures video of
commented saying something along the
lines of social justice warriors are
going through past articles and editing
them too right but I've seen no evidence
of it and well they admit if somebody
provides me with evidence fine
but I have I haven't seen any evidence
of people going through past articles
and added in them to conform they only
think that when people say that I think
there
talking about like articles I think that
the one was the porcelain doll that got
rewritten but any article that gets
rewritten was usually either in danger
of being deleted because it was so low
rated or the original author came back
and wanted to wanted to change it the
only exception to that rule I can think
of is way years ago the guy who wrote
579 the article that's got all the
redaction in it yeah he came back and he
rewrote his article and it was it kind
of stank but then it but then the person
who had previously rewritten it light
was it came back and was like hey you
know what the heck you're changing my
work because it really was lights
article that made it the article that it
is today and then it got that got
changed back but that was that was only
different because they'd already been
rewritten before the original author
came back so it wasn't really completely
their work anymore but there's there's
no conspiracy of social justice warriors
or anybody else the only people who are
in charge of things being rewritten is
our rewrite team which is I think made
up of like three people who just monitor
articles that are low rated they go into
them that ones that are low rated and
they solicit authors experienced authors
on the site who have ideas on how to fix
them and make them better okay so so
from your experience you've seen no
evidence of people or anyone for that
matter political people are not going
into articles changing things no if we
we have a very very strong policy of
author autonomy over works so if your if
your work gets edited and without your
consent you can change it back or staff
will probably change it back for you
before you even notice because we're
usually pretty watchful of that sort of
thing if we can if we see someone going
in and changing articles we're gonna mmm
excuse me we're gonna stop that pretty
quickly and probably banned that person
from the site for being a vandal yeah
well certainly in the time that that
I've been on the site I I've never seen
anyone get away with editing any article
for a prolonged period of time
I mean if I've seen some people you know
just trolling you know what I mean but
it's always being reverted pretty
quickly back to what it originally was
yeah that's that's one of the things
were pretty good at is policing our
contents and making sure that things
that are edited or edited with
authorization because even if we don't
notice it most of our users are gonna be
very very very quick about notifying us
that hey you know this this isn't this
isn't right something's gone wrong here
mmhmm yeah actually I just dawned on me
and before we continue for full
disclosure I am actually a member of the
RPC authority so I'm speaking on a kind
of on behalf of both communities what I
will say is I'm a member of the discord
of the RPC Authority as well I am NOT
gonna be defending half of the stuff
that them guys saying I'm just gonna say
no I've seen I've seen when they flipped
out when cactus won in their Channel
yeah yeah I was actually there will not
happen - Tammy - oh you were there -
yeah yeah that was that was a that was a
mask everything yeah it's just a
disaster for them yeah I think what
originally started it was I was actually
shot in general um DJ cactus actually
added me and said hi right and as soon
as he that thought somebody added
everyone and pegged everyone in the
server and let everybody know that he
was there and after that the chat was
just and it was like an avalanche of
text like it was not possible to
actually scroll up because people were
spamming and they were spamming some
pretty awful awful stuff like yeah I I
just give up I think I messaged at the
time I messaged cactus and mine you have
some balls comin the last escort because
I see well yeah yeah I couldn't believe
he actually showed up
expected anything but what happened I
don't know what he was expecting but I
will give him props for not you know
doing anything like I was ready to
report him for doing shenanigans because
I'm in charge of Internet outrage so if
anyone's gonna get the brunt of more
backlash I'm gonna be the first one to
hear about it but I mean he didn't do
anything he was just answering questions
and being civil and they got pissed off
at us like I really don't get why I mean
I was talking to him
you know after it all died down I think
it was like an hour later but he joined
he got added as a moderator for about an
hour I think because the admins wanted
to talk privately because of the because
of the shitstorm happen and in the
general chat you like nobody was
chatting there that was just shet post
in central for at least half an hour but
they they added them to to the admin
Chuck so I don't know what went on there
but when they added him to the admin
chat that's when everybody absolutely
lost their minds yeah we'll see that see
the reason like from what I've seen DJ
cactus didn't really do anything to
provoke what he got back I don't think I
don't have all the information because I
didn't see what happened in there the
moderator chatter and he thinks oh well
I mean I feel like if anything happened
in the moderator chat they would have
made a public show of it and let
everyone know that hey this is why
everyone was upset but I talked to
connect us about it he said that they
were just talking about you know they
were just kind of making small talk
yeah while in the background everyone in
this community is absolutely losing
their minds that cactus is even there
well you can honestly just think that it
shows that our PSP definitely still has
a lot of growing up to do as a community
they've only been around for what three
weeks now yeah I would say I would say
three weeks
what what I have experienced is because
I have an artist rule on the on the
discord and because I done their logo I
think pretty much everybody knows that
at this point yeah my my original intent
with actually designed in the Maluku is
because I thought the logo that they had
before it was like the shield with the
three arrows I thought that was kind of
derivative of the SCP logo so I thought
I'd actually help them out to make them
stand out as their own thing so that was
my original intent unfortunately this is
the first time I've been in this
position so anything I do is construed
as a political stance even though that
wasn't my intent unfortunately that's
just life so yeah I've seen I've seen
some of their members going around
bragging that they've got you or
something out I don't know what they
mean by that yeah I seen that yesterday
that's another thing that I want to talk
about um Sumerians most recent video
there was there was a lot let's say
three or four it was about three or four
comments that I read that that read
something along the lines of that there
was one dispute that I read and I got
quoted right no the comment the comment
out of context was I said the SCP
community is cancerous right and that
was the screenshot nobody right that was
the comment right but what I was
actually talking about was people
sending me SCP pornography right no I
I'm not a fan of that kind of stuff I'd
like its fur if you are I'm not gonna
judge you if that's your thing that's
fine it's just not me I think that kind
of things counts for us to be perfect
personally but that screenshot is being
toted around like I have completely
denounced the SCP community and in its
entirety I just want to just wanted to
bring that up if you ever see that
screenshot now you knew the context yeah
I mean I think that well regarding SCP
pornography I think that if someone made
of mine I'd be flooded but other than
that you know it's
kind of like if you if you're into that
good for you but I'd really rather not
participate or see it or know that you
you if you can just like allow me to
pretend it doesn't exist that would be
fantastic I mean I I don't mind that it
exists but whenever you're the voice of
scp-049 and people send you those types
of pictures it it gets a wee bit too
personal for me so yeah it's like hey
man yeah anyway I digress
I just thought I'd get that out of the
way they'll let everybody know that I
have been to both sides I've spoke to
people on both sides so I'm not just
sitting from the SCP side or the RPC
side
I like the remain balanced unfortunately
that kind of gets me labelled in my own
person personal life as a fence sitter
which I suppose is fair in this case
because I haven't really denounced
either side but in a way that makes me
the best person to talk about it on a
podcast really I think I don't think
that mutual denunciations are gonna
serve to do anything other than escalate
and make people angry yeah I agree yeah
I think that the only the only thing
that we really need to do is like I was
saying before just get the facts out
there and make it clear that you know
LGBT people or sjw's or whatever you
want to say they've never SCP wasn't
stolen from 4chan by those people those
people people queer people gay people
trans people came from 4chan and were a
large part of the original foundation of
the wiki yeah our original or the
original owner of our chat was gay the
original writer of Abell was very Pro
queer people you know we had a lot of
early articles that had very strong gay
and queer and trans themes in them so
this stuff's been with us since the
beginning it really wasn't until contrar
users like Ecco for Delta came around
that you know homophobia became the norm
for a couple of years
for a couple of years and then even
after that it was that during about
early 2012 these original authors nice
original admins came back and got in
touch with dr. bright it was who is
basically the only remaining admin at
that point and told him hey man like
things have gotten kind of not cool
we should probably work on making
bringing things back to the way they
were yeah yeah the original site in like
oh wait oh nine was probably the closest
it is to right now except that it was
more acceptable to use slurs and kind of
a friendly way because you know they
were just coming from fortune that was
kind of the way things were done yeah
and I've got a quote from clef here
somewhere
oh it's he said I used to toss around
slurs because I knew I'd get them back
but I stopped going to 4chan when I
realized that I had started using it for
reals
mm-hmm and I've also got a thread from
2010 that Gears made here I can I can
send this to you yeah it's a sphere is
basically saying that you know X as
changed its kind of become more x2 the
fortune creepypasta board has become
more of a [ __ ] posting kind of
free-for-all so let's go raid it with
creepypasta I think with all the talk of
raiding going on it's interesting to
talk about back in 2010 the founder of
our site was saying hey X kind of sucks
now let's go make it better with our
content no I never just a managing
perspective yeah well my take on this
and on this thing I see
I think the misconception is that the
original I'd cry was if I was it by gay
or trans people because I because I
don't think it was I think the thing
that started the whole mess was certain
mods reacting in a very head the nuke
button kind of way I think that's what
start yeah this it definitely was yeah
absolutely and I mean a lot of people
have staff doing as well
from this to you am I am i right and not
because I think because I didn't really
knew the facts about it so I can't
really a lot of people have stepped down
either directly as a result of their
actions and escalating stuff or because
the drama got to be so much they
couldn't take it anymore I think that
the only person who really did anything
that didn't you know resign or quit was
bright who said that you know who cares
what the original people thought which
is what just what I've been addressing
all that is because his comment was both
very not necessary and very inaccurate I
think that did a lot more than anything
to spark people saying well oh
definitely you're definitely right on
that because in the madacorp video
that's he had a big point of contention
with that specific quote from from
bright yeah I'm not gonna take him to
fascist he's just not always he doesn't
really have a way with words I think he
was just trying to defend his queer
members and in doing so he kind of said
something that was both not true and
likely to instigate backlash and how it
was phrased so just really a perfect
storm of not the right thing to say and
not the right time to say it yeah pretty
much but I mean as a conclusion to all
this I think it's mostly it's mostly
over the the dramas mostly over at this
point what what I can see happening is
there are people all of the people that
I see that are continuing to bring stuff
like this up are people making snarky
comments under my videos bringin up
gender in a snarky way and promoting the
RPC foundation can I just say I really
hate it when people do that it's like
yeah if you if you really prefer RPC
there's nothing wrong with that like I
I'm it there was a video called SCP
explained it was from the SCP
Declassified subreddit module 'm
actually wrote it because it was called
SCP explained i get comments under that
even i complaining about it's been taken
over by a sh
aw is like the reason that frustrates me
is because people supposedly left the
SCP wiki to get away from politics and
vuelven getting involved in this kind of
stuff and you're through in your
politics and other people's faces I
don't I don't get it
stop talking about it move on go to the
RPC create really cool stuff I encourage
it I made your logo for God's sake the
RPC authority goes I had I had some hope
for them when they started it's there I
have less now because I feel like
they've gotten too bogged down and
trying to just be always a response to
what SCP is doing like I'd really love
to see them go and just do something you
know [ __ ] crazy and go out there like
break break out of what SCP is and just
deuce do your own thing do something
totally different
but I mean from what their site is like
they've got object classes they've got
you know the same formatting they've got
the same basic premise the same
structure like I feel like it's a missed
opportunity to go and do their own thing
and do something really different
well well at this stage like as you said
there by 3 weeks old they still have a
lot of growing to do from what I've seen
in the art community there there there
is a lot of original ideas I've seen
time will tell nobody can really call it
at this point I don't think but they do
have original ideas and they are trying
to go their own way with it I just the
only thing that still is lurking around
there's people on the RPC side on the
SCP side that they're just spying on
each other I'm looking at what the other
sides did that's the only remnant of the
drama but I can stand just obsessing
over what the other is doing yeah yeah
just is yeah I think that's what the
conclusion of this well of our talk is
anyway I just want people to move on
just let live and let live that kind of
thing people don't wrong allow all sides
ok but this isn't a one-sided thing even
though some people love the point-like
or paint it that way it's
really not one-sided thing mistakes were
made on both sides as far as I can see
you know what I mean I mean I'm not
omniscient or anything I don't have all
the facts in front of me I know that
some of our users have gone out and
father I know that we we we banned one
person who went over to raid and they've
got some other Raiders I don't think
that those are our members because well
you know usually they're they're not
smart enough to keep their mouth shut
about that but I know that a lot of the
abuse that's gotten hurled at some of
our gay and trans and LGBT members has
been really horrific I don't know if
that's reflective of our PC as a whole I
think that definitely they've got some
members who are attracted more about
being anti-gay than anti mod overreach
but I think I hopefully they can outgrow
that and I mean as as far as people
talking about but that's not like SCP
always gets brought up I don't even know
what's number 27 21 from what I have
seen dot god I've regretted a lot right
now personal politics aside I mean I'm
not really too keen on it myself right
but I think it's flawed
I think it's they were trying to do
something that a lot of people who read
it are getting a very shallow
interpretation of it but I also feel
like it could have been done in a way
that made its point more clear yeah I
mean let me take away that
interpretation that's that's completely
fair by the way actually can use
actually fix the Dynamo Brigade and I'm
not or we can do what we've done is
we've moved it to a category where it's
protected it doesn't have any votes on
it at all anymore but there's nothing we
can do about turning off download sir on
just that article or removing downloads
without permanent damage then yeah
without doing something like making a
bunch of fake accounts to upload it back
up to where it was I think we feel that
would be just disingenuous and kind of a
shady thing to do mmm yeah the protected
status that we've made for it is
probably the best possible solution that
we have right now given the limitations
of wiki nut
yeah that's vertical and it is
unfortunate permanent damage like one of
the authors of that article left the
site because they were getting harassed
both about 2721 and about their 4k entry
destiny manifested which is which a lot
of people from what I can tell people
from the RPC Authority were mad at it
because it kind of has you know anti
American Empire themes but I mean I feel
like people should have the freedom to
express that and the freedom to be able
to say you know this is let me let me
talk about America through this through
this article yeah and it was a cool
article had george w bush debating
emperor Joshua Norton it was a really
cool figure initiative in American
history that I encourage anyone
listening to this to look up because
it's very entertaining yeah I mean like
that like there's there's articles that
deal with politics you have to be able
to talk about like from the authors from
the writers perspective everyone's gonna
have a political opinion definitely but
it's just whenever it resorts the
Dunnville Bregan over or stuff written
systems should be based on quality of
writing and content to me absolutely be
motivated by political bias and whether
that when he is like it or not on the
RPC site the people that I'm not saying
years old that he's obviously all done
to it but the people that did don't vote
that satellite thing that was
politically motivated which is kind of
ironic considering stream running yeah
it's a very ironic considering the
genesis of the RPC if you guys want it
if anyone wants to avoid politics you've
got a we can't just be all politics but
my own
yeah pretty much if you want to have a
political free an area where you can
write if you don't want to have writing
with political themes that's fine but
you can't go around and then make a
political statements by attacking
article with themes that you don't like
yeah sense to me it's just as political
if not more political than writing
something with political themes to it
well yeah because you can't ignore it a
dynamo Brigade like that whereas if if I
read something that I don't politically
agree with I can just choose to move on
yeah you just choose to not engage with
that like I disagree with this so maybe
you'll you can talk to the author maybe
you can leave a comment but you don't go
and try to destroy something and mass
because you disagree with what it's
trying to say well yeah because that is
a form of censorship what whether you
were the elected or not that you're
trying to censor somebody's opinion you
know because because I've seen people
complain that when when large groups of
social justice warriors do that because
I'm not a fan of social justice warriors
to be honest ain't it they they're
really guilty of that kind of stuff do
you know really anyone who takes their
own ideology so seriously to the point
that they can't listen to any
disagreement or take any kind of dissent
no matter what under the political
spectrum you're at you're your other
ones yeah you're not really contributing
Danny thing you're just destroying
difference listening to each other then
we're not gonna be able to have a civil
discourse it's just gonna be bickering
and fighting and then you know lead to
things like massive down GoPro Gades
yeah i mean in the interest of fairness
like the RPC has received some of that
too from from what I've heard I'm not
again I don't know the the facts about
it but each each moderator team of each
site Knight is very vocal saying don't
do it because I think they that's one
thing that SCP and RPC do agree on they
don't want that vote brigades because
it's just kinda productive and solves
nothing
yeah I know that in our own chat in site
19 we've been pretty
pretty active about shutting down down
but brigades whenever they happened
because one it's a really annoying thing
to take over chat we just we just shut
down people whenever they get mad about
our PC we're like hey guys let's talk
about something else because when if
people get mad whatever there's been a
spinoff wiki there's always been a
certain population who thinks the best
thing to do is to do and bother them
when they're trying to go do their own
thing yeah it just doesn't work mom no
it doesn't accomplish anything but like
from for anybody that's watching the
that is a member of the RPC and think
that this isn't like a balanced
interview I really don't know what to
say because I I think we've both been
pretty fair talking about it I'm sure
you'll let us all know in the comments
but as far as as far as I can tell it's
been pretty fair like I'm not trying to
castigate the entire community I'd love
to see them make some cool articles you
would see one of the major problems that
I have with with both sides of this
debate is people Tannen the the entire
community of SCP and RPC with one label
and the communities are just too
complicated to do that everybody I think
yeah or they're just looking at one
person from SCP or RPC and saying this
person's one opinion speaks for the
entirety of that group so we should
crucify them for what this person said
yeah pretty much yeah I'm not a funnel
oh yeah but I will say that this is
definitely the most impressive spin-off
wiki that's or independent wiki that's
ever been made because we've got a lot
of we've got tons of these over the
years but this was the first one that
actually got any kind of real traction
yeah definitely because the thing the
only other one that I've seen is the
chaos insurgency one but every I don't
even think it exists anymore does it
I was checking it up not too long ago it
looks like it was semi actively within
the last you may have finally kicked the
bucket in terms of just no longer being
active and also I'll show you for RPC
whether whether or not they have long
term success
like I hope that they do because that
would mean that they grow and evolve as
a community to moving into focusing on
their own content and making their own
stuff and even if they even if they
don't succeed you know I'd love to see
those authors who had good ideas and
creative thoughts be able to come back
to STP and be able to bring those ideas
back and make their content work and on
the larger platform well I mean that
that's I agree 100% I mean not to me
that's the end game of what I'd like to
see I'd like to see both communities
helping each other or at the very least
working together without having to
resort to passing contests you know
absolutely absolutely I feel like it's
kind of interesting also seeing RPC grow
because they're they're kind of going
through a lot of the stages that SCP
went through over years really really
really quickly so seeing how their mods
deal with things like membership and
voting and brigades this is all stuff
that we tackle it in the early days with
trolls like Haggar who came in and
deleted our goals and had done of a
brigades which led to us having closed
membership it was you know it's it's
cool to see the same thing is happening
again but a different time framing on a
different scale well I suppose because
as far as I can tell there's a good fee
others have moved over to the RPC so
with those authors probably brings
expertise as the Hydra correctly mounted
stuff like them so they kind of
Providence who's gone over there as
Vaughn pin seer who was the author of
the hateful star and SCP Selleck there I
was among other things I don't know of
any other authors you know with with
prominent works who have gone over
yeah I mean Vaughn pensiero is the only
one that I've seen purely because I
think he was just so so big compared to
the other ones because the heedful star
is pretty pretty well received as a
whole candy built around it yeah so I
think that people have been comparing
that to fishmonger but that's it's a
really not a comparable situation
because fishmonger was was probably the
reason why we have the ideology of there
is no Canon now because before he left
there really was sort of one loosely
connected storyline driving the site and
then he left and took a big huge chunk
of that out and we kind of were left
looking sure than going well what do we
do now and the solution was well there
is no Canon you know you can have these
articles that exist that can contradict
each other but as long as you follow the
theme of SCP you can you can write
whatever you want is so much better yeah
no definite so well you know it's uh it
is it's only comfortable in that an
author with some well-known important
works deletes them off the site it's not
like fishmonger where he flipped
everybody off burned everything to the
ground and left a huge hole like there's
a hole but it's a much smaller hole and
it's already mostly healed the high/low
that actually happened oh that was years
ago I believe that was around 2010 or so
he was a major author he was a mod for a
while and he got demoted banned came
back banned again came back and then I
think I don't know what the final straw
was I think it might have been sock
puppet accounts mm-hmm but I also think
that it's kind of uh believed I mean I
believe that that was kind of a flimsy
excuse to get rid of him because he was
just way too much trouble more trouble
than he was worth so it's the difference
between an author independently choosing
to pull their own works and move them to
a different platform to be I guess sort
of a big fish in a small pond and a
major author
getting banned and an inactive hateful
spite ripping everything they have off
the wiki and saying we'll figure out the
holes that I left for yourselves you
jerks yeah very very different
situations yeah because I'm not actually
sure what bonpensiero
like I don't know why he left was it was
a purely political was he then he have
trouble with mods in the past or and not
incident that he have trouble with mods
no I don't know if any recent trouble he
had with mods before he left I really
don't know what the reason he left was I
think that it's really the only person
who can say is him that's for you the
SCP wiki respects him for wanting to go
off and do his own thing and if he ever
wants to bring his own stuff back that's
fine and if he doesn't we wish him the
best of luck on our PC authority yeah
definitely I think I think the the best
thing to do is just again I'm like a
broken record like but you know live and
let live that kind of antagonizing each
other isn't gonna lead to anything
productive no it's really not there was
there was something about tales that I
wanted to ask you because at the start
of my youtube career it was I did
nothing but eels was there was there
always a desire to have collections of
Till's
you know for example the tales of mr.
collector the lump party till like you
know what I mean like tales that were
enter lengths and could be told and in a
serial forma or definitely like I was
saying before the original the original
conceit for tales was they were kind of
the behind the scenes of scps
so you had things like the the tooth or
the witch girl log the 2:39 incident and
going back to talk about fishmonger he
had this thing I think was linked with a
chest motif I forget what it was called
like a hooker mercury something check or
something I don't know but it was
basically different authors a series of
tales where every author would just pick
up from where the last one left off with
no pre-planning I can't believe I forgot
the name of that oh it's gonna drive me
crazy I know that cliff has one story
for a minute on the tip of my tongue
it's gonna drive me insane this it was
like rook something or chess or like
check or something something something
like that but yeah we there's always
been serial stories serial tales the
desire to have these things existing in
the same universe I actually feel like
the tales of mr. collector was a very
influential story because that I think
the structure of that and the castling
castling is put it was tall finally
Gosling clef or waxes author page was a
reference to it yeah castling castling
was fishmongers thing no that was like a
like an early serial story style project
but yeah the tales of mr. collectors
definitely was very influential on tale
series and the subsequent development of
the cannons mm-hmm but an awesome way to
for people to tell stories and develop
ideas well yeah well yeah I mean
whenever I first find out about the wiki
after reading a few documents it was
actually heels that made me create my
youtube channel because I thought the
documents at that point there were some
exceptions but mostly the documents
didn't really tell a story from what I
read anyway they're probably as examples
but whenever I find the Till's that was
when I really started to get into
because I mean I'm a bit biased but the
Lombardy tales were pretty awesome like
I mean III can see the Lombardi tales as
being a TV show oh for sure do you know
what I mean like here whenever I was
reading those Lombardi tales it felt
like a noir kind of
detective draw I could see it in my head
you know what I mean
yeah like man is such a good storyteller
man is probably one of our best the
site's best writers oh so good mom
though those tales were just I mean I've
smoked them out a few times and I've
asked them as he ever gonna do a sequel
to the lumbar details he's been really
diplomatic and said if I feel like Dana
and I can make it good I will would have
not promising anything and I'm not
complaining cuz I don't want him to
write something that he doesn't believe
in because that's just kind of
productive but ah if he ever does any
more Lombardi tales I'll be a happy mom
not they oh yeah oh and speaking of
trying to write things that are highly
in demand I am thinking of writing more
of my history of the universe essays for
those of you out there who have been
waiting for years to see if any more of
that is gonna come down the pipeline
Noah nice Thanks yeah I just feel like
now I've just been by recent events I've
realized that a lot of people have a
pretty serious misunderstanding of our
history yeah recent history and I think
that having it out there and having it
written down would allow people to be
more informed a hundred and one I mean
it if this was already available I think
there would be there would have been a
lot of arguments potentially nipped in
the bud yeah that's that's that's part
of it because I've been thinking about
it I've honestly been been thinking
something like this could happen for a
long time like oh man if people don't
understand you know what came before
would be really easy to misunderstand
how things have gone like this and now
it's kind of happened and I'm kind of
like I didn't do the thing I think I
think everybody can relate about always
needed to do something then something
happens to me makes you think well she
should have done the thing man but I'm
thinking either my first project is
going to be maybe more direct addressing
of the situation with maybe a queer gay
history of the wiki or maybe just a
straight-up
continuation of the essay series going
from 2012 2012 on yeah that's cool
I mean like what where would you I mean
this is kind of a weird question but
where do you see like the foundation as
it is nine where do you see its its
proper origins because I know it started
on acts but from what we see on the wiki
nine what was its whenever it started to
come and its own like it's whenever you
notice that what I mean yeah yeah
definitely
I think that the wiki started to become
less of a creepypasta series and more of
a collaborative fiction project once it
was on wiki dot I feel like 4chan was
where it was born and then be moved to
edit this and that was kind of a
transitional then once we run wiki dot
that was when people like gears people
like bright to a lesser extent the
administrator diode Oh early users who
were I can I can say this person because
they're not going to get harassed
because they're not in the site anymore
but Diogenes died oh gee I don't know
they were an early author
yeah they wrote uh I believe they wrote
the gender flipper and some other stuff
here let me and they wrote one that I
really like that's like a mulberry bush
that does stuff let me let me let me
find him I'm going to like Diogenes yeah
agent Diogenes personnel file yeah they
were an early author who was you know
non-binary oh they were oh yeah they
wrote that jigsaw puzzle the the jigsaw
puzzle that makes you crazy and I don't
think I've seen them yeah it's five five
one and they wrote the chimpanzee that
wants to destroy society the chimpanzee
that wants to destroy Isis yeah I think
I wrote a little foundation tale with
that one it's monkey business which was
a can idea that someone had and I just
turned into a goofy tale a task force of
five monkeys going around fighting crime
yeah it fits well in the law foundation
cannon know
yeah really does but yeah man but when
we had a lot of early authors cane
passes chrome and gears bright these
people who wrote the early major
articles articles like Abel clockworks
the old man like overheard collections
yeah like that's defecate stuff existed
before but it really found its place to
be used properly on wikidot once people
could write proper stories about and not
just write these creepypasta style
entries like you know I mean we became
more free to write what we wanted to
write yes so that would have been around
2011 2009 Oh mm oh yeah 2007 2008 was
mostly on 4chan and edit this and then
those platforms proved to be unsuitable
so the administrator move the committee
the committee the community to wiki dot
which is a really lucky break for us
because as far as wiki farms go like
wiki de has problems but they're
definitely the best out of what was
available at the time and probably still
what's available currently yeah actually
that really that reminds me of a
question that I really do need to ask
this is all rumors I think but I have
heard there was some people talking
about there is a there is a project that
the wikis gonna be implemented to move
the site elsewhere is this true
well right what's happening right now is
a renewal of a project that first
started in 2012 and kind of crashed and
burned because our lead technical person
was not really suited for the job and
that's all there's a there's a ton of
drama behind that I'm just gonna I'm not
gonna get into it that's oh that's a
whole other like if you think that this
is the worst drama the wiki has ever
seen who the boy ooh boy but yeah that
was that was the first time we tried to
move off-site and then it kind of was
dormant until it hasn't been until now
that we've really had the technical
expertise and the people to try and move
on to a platform of our own so that does
have an element of truth then he's
already cannon
to move like what would do is a
technical reason or is it for other
reasons it's it's it's for technical
reasons wikidot doesn't give us full
control over our content so like we
talked about earlier we can't remove
down votes for down foot brigades we
only have so much control over how the
site looks at the interface functions
and we have problems with like a lot of
our content being buried like a lot of
tails just get posted and get buried
because there's no good way to access
them or things like that so we just want
to be able to have full control and be
able to serve our users better yeah
that's for I mean the more the more
control people have over the site the
better I mean I mean mainly for the
correction of votes I mean that just
seems unfair to me Mon I mean I I mean
from like even if I was looking at the
RPC I would hit any of their original
articles the beatdown forget it you know
like say they had something on the site
that had 300 and I went but from 300 to
ten within the space of two weeks
that's not fair money yeah it's really
not cool so if you had the ability to
correct that that would be fantastic and
also for general stability because there
have been times where wiki dot has
crashed or some features have stopped
working and you know it we live under
the constant possibility that one day
something in wiki does gonna break and
they're not gonna be able to fix it and
that's gonna be the end of that yeah
that would just be the end of everything
yeah they'll be a nightmare but actually
that this is an older question do you
actually have a database like an
off-site database that is kept up to
date or is it all done the wiki no we do
we do save I know that at least one
admin snoreless n' who's no longer
active was the last I checked regularly
downloading copies of the wiki to make
sure that you know all the content was
somewhere backup them to exist so you
know if wiki that went down we could go
dormant for a while we work
a next-gen platform solution then come
back and still have all the content
although a lot of stuff would still be
lost like comments and votes and forums
and history and what-have-you
I don't think that could be saved if
wiki dot went down but the content
itself you know the core of the site
could be could be and everything else
can be rebuilt on top of that yeah I
think the only way you could possibly
see if the comments would be using that
wayback machine but I don't know wait
there's a way to port forums I think
that we figured out oh no no sorry we
kind of we've kind of been talking to
each other at some points but I just say
that there is a way to pour comments now
with wiki dot active but definitely if I
went down wayback machine would probably
be your only option to see them yeah man
that would take a long time though
because I think if somebody had to
choose between the content of the site
on the comments of the site they would
choose the content so yeah oh for sure
for sure so on the on the on the future
look into the future is there any major
changes apart from moving and getting a
more stable kind of platform these these
plan on implement then or nothing mmm
like super major I think we're right in
the middle of the 4k contest right now
obviously yeah it's mostly just it's
good we've kind of a decentralized staff
structure like the admins are the ones
in charge but anyone can propose you
know policy proposals or changes or
what-have-you things like that yeah
right now our wiki walk
wrapping up and that's kind of been
restoring cross links and across you
know being able to wiki walk from one
article to another and that's been a
pretty successful I think change and
major change in site culture from when I
start the project then handed it over to
Khan well we went from kind of
cross-linking being frowned upon to
cross-linking being standard practice
again which is good because that's
that's that's gonna be a way that people
can find content that's gonna be the way
that the we can thrive in the future
yeah I mean I I like I always use cross
links always
yeah Sam yeah but I think that it's
really gonna be the same incremental
process of trying to improve the way we
do things and trying to do the the best
we can and serve our users in the most
fair way possible yeah mana I don't
think you could you could ask for
anything anything else as long as
everything stays fair I mean I would say
that the drama that's happened probably
both communities have learned something
from it even though it's mostly a train
wreck I'm trying to I'm trying to look
at the bright side a little bit as we're
closing here you know yeah yeah
hopefully hopefully both people have
learned something I've also learned
something not that not to talk on public
forums about things or else people will
screencap what you said and use it as
ammunition against people don't do that
guys it's not cool no one should you
don't take people's words out of context
yeah because then then then when you use
it the person's gonna come make a public
statement saying you know actually I was
talking about porn you're just gonna
look at goofball yeah like people are
gonna take you seriously yeah it's not
really a good really family-friendly
rebuttal either it's like I was talking
about porn oh okay okay it's kind of not
better but okay you know not saying that
the community is cancer just the parts
of it that are drawing the things that
I've voice with yeah do it do any doing
those things yeah there are elements of
the community that is cancerous as there
are elements of the RPC community or any
or any community so closing remarks what
would you like to say just as we're
closing up thank you very much for
having me I've never done and
interview-style thing like this before
so it was it was quite a bit of fun too
you know to speak to you speak about
the recent events talk about a little
bit about site history in the 4000
contest yeah yeah two-thirds of those
things are some of my favorite things
nice okay and if any of you out there
are curious as to the stuff that I've
contributed to the wiki you can check
out my author page on the wiki doctoral
jets file I've got a little over a
hundred and twenty SCPs you could read
and quite a few tales and essays to
that's impressive
thank you so if you made it through the
whole podcast that's great if there is
anything that you would like either me
or ruj it to address that we covered in
the podcast put your thoughts in the
comments section I'm gonna make another
follow up podcast addressing all those
points just to make it as fair as
possible and create a dialogue obviously
I don't really want to make a hobbit I'd
have commented on every single drama but
I think it's necessary this time mainly
because I was talking to somebody from
the SCP wiki and there is nobody from
the complete opposite side got a chance
to talk that is if anybody cares if
nobody if if we get to a feedback at all
that's fine we'll just leave it at that
okay thank you very much for listening
under you're all dismissed goodbye